why do you think psychologically you
wanted to be an actor well I had the
advantage man where
you know my grandfather was quite a
well-known cinematographer you know who
then became an editor later in his life
and so he had friends who were in the
business and they all started in the
services of the armed services they were
the guys that shot all the film in the
various War zones through the second
world war and they moved into the film
industry after the war and my mum's
Godfather for instance became a
notoriously cheap television producer in
Australia and so notoriously cheap that
he managed to con his uh goddaughter
into being the caterer and that's how I
started because I was I was on film sets
and I would imagine your parents looked
at the actors as like gods they were
Caterers and they would see these people
who were being treated in such things
this is Australian TV
back in the late 60s early 70s right and
what you're talking about it's just not
that now you know this is a group of
gypsies yes you know who uh do the job
for the love right you know so that's
what I got infected by and learning that
not every door on a set went somewhere
and learning that you can totally fool
people that you're in the submarine even
though it's made of wood it's
fascinating yeah and I loved all that
stuff in other words when you see a door
that's so mysterious where does the
store lead and obviously I would go and
open it you would at six yeah at six I
would walk around film sets and go and
see where things went but also you know
because then later in the scene and
you're watching the actors play it how
they come they enter an X and but you
know this is a freestanding room it's
not a room in a building when you talk
about acting in kids it's not considered
the most masculine thing did kids tease
you because you started acting at six
for sure they did yeah
it never really got to be a problem
because I did it a lot of the stuff I
did was shows that they didn't see
they're on late at night and stuff like
that but I do remind people quite often
when they start talk in terms of tough
guy and blah blah blah it's like mate I
put makeup on for a living you know
that's what I do you know and it's it's
purely for me it's an art form now I've
been very lucky in that I've been able
to use my body to do my job whether it's
to expand or to shrink don't get really
strong or whatever you know and I'm That
Kind of actor I like to it to be you
know uh an all-encompassing experience
um do you still like it but you know I I
love it you love it
I walk to the camera
on a set every day and I absolutely know
this is where I should be